TY BURRELL: Now
that I've learned
self-driving cars
aren't that far off,
what about ride sharing?
Are companies like
Lyft and Uber going
to be part of the solution?
How you doing?
All right?
What are the odds?
You are John Zimmer,
President of Lyft.
You got it.
Can you drive.
Yeah, I think I got this.
You don't sound
very confident.
I'm going to get in anyway.
All right, where
do you want to go to?
TY BURRELL: Right here is great.
[laughter]
This is as far as I'm going.
Thanks, buddy.
JOHN ZIMMER: Yeah.
TY BURRELL: Well, I'm
on a mission to learn
about the future of cars.
And I have two kids.
I'm very concerned
about their future
and about carbon emissions.
How much does Lyft think
about that kind of stuff?
JOHN ZIMMER: That was one
of the original reasons
why we wanted to do this.
The environmental toll of
having just over one person
in every car is just horrible.
TY BURRELL: How pie in the
sky is a driverless city?
Yeah, it's very real.
It's the only way we can double
population in our old cities.
Right.
JOHN ZIMMER: Imagine
this experience right now
with no cars parked in a
city, maybe half as many roads
because the rides themselves
are more efficient.
The cost will come
down to the point
where you can get a ride
anywhere for under $5.
So it's like the ultimate
form of public transportation
door-to-door.
When you have autonomous, the
economics work out that way.
It feels like one of
those moments in history
where we can either move
forward in the right way
or we can move forward
in the wrong way
because it's such a
crucial turning point.
JOHN ZIMMER: Mm-hmm.
The ultimate outcome
should be clean fuel
and should be
autonomous and have
the opportunity for people to
share those autonomous rides.
That is a big win.
And electric is a
big part of that.